[Música]
el presidente de Cuba Miguel díaz-canel
seguirá cinco años más en el poder
asamblea nacional lo designó nuevamente
por una votación casi unánime de esta
manera el legislativo cubano comenzó su
próxima legislatura
la llamada ley no digas gay se aplicará
en todos los grados escolares en el
estado de Florida en Estados Unidos el
departamento de Educación del Estado
decidió extender la prohibición de
enseñar sobre identidad de género y
orientación sexual que antes era solo
para el jardín infantil y la escuela
primaria Tenemos reporte desde Miami
y fracasó un segundo intento de cese al
fuego en Sudán el ejército y los
paramilitares de las fuerzas de apoyo
rápido pactaron frenar las hostilidades
durante 24 horas a partir de la noche de
este miércoles pero testigos afirman que
los combates continúan miles huyen dejar
Tum la capital
Bienvenidos a una nueva ronda
informativa de Franz 24 yo soy María
Clara calle
iniciamos en Cuba donde la asamblea
nacional ratificó al presidente Miguel
Díaz canel para un segundo periodo
presidencial de cinco años con 459 votos
a favor de los 462 legisladores que
estaban presentes también reelegieron al
vicepresidente Salvador Valdés Meza
recordemos que en 2018 días canel fue
elegido como el primer presidente por
fuera de la familia Castro desde la
revolución pero apostó por un
continuismo de las ideas políticas de
Fidel y Raúl durante su primer gobierno
la economía cubana cayó un 11% en 2020 a
causa de la pandemia del covid 19 y
ahora el reelecto presidente deberá
seguir enfrentando la difícil situación
económica empeorada por la inflación y
las sanciones de Estados Unidos
a continuación vamos a escuchar lo que
nos dijo previamente un invitado al
respecto
sería simplista acusar a Díaz canel de
ser responsable por la profunda crisis
económica y política que sufre el
régimen cubano Este es el resultado de
60 años de políticas equivocadas tanto
económicas como
políticas y sociales que han llevado al
país a esta situación
a desafortunadamente para días canel le
tocó a él gobernar en estos últimos
cinco años en cualquier otro lugar del
mundo los cinco años de presidencia de
Díaz canel le hubieran ocasionado por la
renuncia o la pérdida de esta elección
solamente en un régimen como el cubano
un presidente de una incompetencia tan
Escandalosa puede ser reelecto y
reelecto de manera
tan digamos mayoritaria la Corte Suprema
de Justicia de Estados Unidos extendió
dos días más la pausa que ordenó para
decidir de fondo sobre la píldora
abortiva mifepristona el juez Samuel
habilitó precisó que la sentencia final
se conocerá el viernes la corte de
debate en la orden del juez Federal de
Texas
que impulsó limitar la disponibilidad de
la pastilla alegando que la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos la fda No tenía sustentos
clínicos suficientes para haberla
aprobado hace 20 años mientras la corte
toma una decisión la mifepristona sigue
disponible en el país Este es un
medicamento que se combina con el
misoprostol Y ambos son el método más
utilizado en Estados Unidos para
interrumpir de manera voluntaria los
embarazos
otra de las noticias en Estados Unidos
es que en el estado de Florida se
extendió a la educación secundaria la
ley conocida como no digas gay el
departamento de Educación votó este
miércoles para prohibir desde el grado
cuarto hasta el Dúo décimo que se den
clases sobre identidad de género y
orientación sexual hasta ahora la
restricción solo aplicaba al jardín
infantil y a la escuela primaria nuestro
corresponsal en Miami Anthony belchinos
la junta de Educación del estado de la
Florida ha aprobado expandir a grados
Superiores de las escuelas en la
polémica ley del no digas gay que
prohíbe expresamente hablar sobre
condición sexual o identidad de género
en las escuelas públicas del Estado
desde el grado 4 al 12 es decir hasta
los 18 años de edad esta nueva regla que
por cierto no requiere de una aprobación
legislativa forma parte de los esfuerzos
que ha estado haciendo el gobernador de
Florida el republicano ron de santis en
los últimos tiempos para llevar a cabo
una agenda mucho más conservadora con
medidas como
o también con la restricción del aborto
a las seis semanas de gestación entre
otras cosas la nueva regulación prohíba
expresamente que los maestros brinden
elecciones sobre estas cuestiones de
identidad de género A menos que la
instrucción sea requerida por los
estándares estatales o sea parte de una
clase de salud de la que los Padres
pueden decidir si sus hijos participen o
no la violación de la regla podría
resultar en la suspensión o incluso la
revocación de la licencia de enseñanza
de un educador Ya el año pasado el
gobernador de santis apoyó una ley de
este tipo pero dirigida a los niños de
hasta 9 años la medida ya en ese
entonces creó una gran controversia
entre los grupos lgbtq Incluso el
presidente de Estados Unidos o Joe biden
se ha mostrado en contra porque
considera que es una regla
discriminatoria pero detrás de todo esto
estarían las intenciones del gobernador
de Florida para presentarse a las
primarias en republicanas de Cara a las
elecciones presidenciales de 2024 a
pesar de que él aún no ha confirmado sus
intenciones en noticias de África ya son
cinco días de conflicto en Sudán este
miércoles fracasó un segundo intento de
cese al fuego entre el ejército y los
paramilitares de la fuerza de apoyo
rápido Far en teoría este debía haber
comenzado a las seis de la tarde hora
local pero testigos han denunciado que
los enfrentamientos continúan en la
capital jartum de donde han huido miles
de personas los países vecinos como
Egipto y Arabia Saudita habían
presionado para esta tregua y poder
evacuar así a sus ciudadanos este
miércoles sin embargo el ejército
sudanés informó de la salida de Sudán de
177 tropas de la fuerza aérea egipcia
los combates dejan al menos 270 muertos
y 2600 heridos según el Ministerio de
salud sudanés
otra de las consecuencias de los
combates en Sudán es que miles de
personas continúan encerradas en sus
casas sin poder asistir a centros de
salud ni comprar alimentos que son cada
vez más escasos además organismos
humanitarios internacionales denuncian
que el fuego cruzado y las constantes
agresiones también han imposibilitado el
tránsito de ayuda humanitaria en jartum
veamos el informe de Max Pérez Gallardo
Sudán al borde de una gran crisis
humanitaria Es solo el quinto día de
combates en jartum pero los residentes
de la capital ya experimentan el pánico
por la falta de servicios básicos a raíz
de los enfrentamientos entre el ejército
y las FARC el suministro de agua y luz
han sido cortados en ciertas partes de
la ciudad además muchos comercios han
cerrado sus puertas por el miedo a ser
objeto de la violencia lo que ha
provocado un desabasto en medicamentos e
insumos básicos
esta colapsada desde el sábado pasado
Aquí no hay agua en las tuberías ni en
los depósitos el agua almacenada está
casi agotada
a pesar de la urgencia por ayuda las
organizaciones humanitarias se
encuentran imposibilitadas para actuar
Naciones Unidas ha denunciado agresiones
y violencia sexual en contra de
trabajadores humanitarios Durante los
combates en jartum además la movilidad
de asistencia es sumamente compleja
consecuencia del constante intercambio
bélico entre ambos bandos
la verdad es que en estos momentos es
casi imposible prestar ninguna
asistencia humanitaria en jartum y sus
alrededores recibimos llamadas de
diversas organizaciones y personas
atrapadas pidiendo que las evacuen desde
hace cuatro días la gente no tiene agua
ni comida y la electricidad ha sido
totalmente desconectada en algunos
lugares
en 2022 Sudán se posicionó en el lugar
172 en el índice de desarrollo humano
uno de los más bajos del mundo el
conflicto actual podría acentuar esta
condición y generar una nueva crisis
humanitaria en una nación africana
Emmanuel apareció en público por primera
vez desde que promulgó la polémica ley
que reforma las pensiones en Francia y
la respuesta que recibió fue un gran
abucheo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el mandatario visitó una fábrica en la
región de alsacia allí le respondieron
con pancartas y gritos pidiéndole la
renuncia incluso algunos trabajadores
cortaron brevemente la energía eléctrica
dentro de la edificación esto se suma a
las protestas de los últimos tres meses
que rechazan la reforma que sube la edad
de retiro de 62 a 64 años macron
prometió un plan de 100 días de acción
para adelantar los nuevos proyectos del
gobierno en esa idea intenta
reconectarse de nuevo con la gente Así
se pronunció el mandatario tras el
abucheo en la fábrica
y normal es normal que se exprese esta
ira Ahí está también hay personas que
tienen otras motivaciones que vinieron a
saludarme otras que me están apoyando
estuvieron conmigo esta mañana en una
empresa que refleja la diversidad de
Francia no escuché ninguna movilización
esta vez para poder salir adelante ir a
las empresas y hacer cosas sin embargo
se nota ese en ojo no esperaba otra cosa
pero no me va a impedir seguir
moviéndome por el país porque hay que
seguir actuando y salir adelante
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]